be sure to follow me on Twitter there
you can keep up with all the updates
from comics explained and talk to me
directly what's going on guys this is
Rob and since a lot of you requested
videos are more condensed than time
friendly I figured I'd launch a
companion series through my longer
videos called in seven minutes now the
aim of this series is to give you all
the same information you'll see in my
longer character and team videos but
without all the extra fluff and so in
this video what we're going to be doing
is we're going to be talking about
daredevil
so Matt Murdock first appeared in Marvel
Comics with daredevil number one in 1964
and he was created by Stan Lee and Bill
Everett now the origin of daredevil
follows that he saved a blind man from
being hit by a truck carrying
radioactive material but he was exposed
to the radioactive material himself and
lost his sight in the process and as a
result his other senses were enhanced
which allowed him to view the world
around him using these enhanced senses
and now in order for him to cover her
son's medical bills and with little
offering in terms of boxing matches Matt
Murdock's father Jack Murdock turned to
a mob boss for boxing matches to
actually get the money he needed but it
was also during this time that Matt
Murdock would begin training himself on
how to use his senses now eventually
Matt Murdock enrolled and attended
Columbia University where he actually
met foggy Nelson and in addition to this
Matt chose to attend one of his father's
boxing matches but due to his son
attending one of his matches Jack
Murdock who had actually learned that
all of his victories up to this point
were fixed chosen not to throw the match
which he was informed to do by the mob
boss himself and as a result he was
killed by one of the mob bosses men now
following the death of his father Matt
Murdock graduated from Columbia
University with foggy Nelson
he established Nelson and Murdock Law
Offices and then he used his father's
uniform to basically create a uniform
for himself and then undertook the
mantle of daredevil now over the course
of the 1960's leading it to the 1970s
daredevil actually saw several changes
which included his costume being changed
from his a yellow costume to his
signature red costume with a double D on
the front of it as well as a creation of
some of his most notable villains in the
form of owl bullseye and gladiator in
addition to meeting spider-man and
teaming up with Black Widow now by the
late 1970s a series was suffering from a
decline in readership but it was
actually revived in 1979 by Frank Miller
with issue number 158 of daredevil now
where previous stories had kept
daredevil in a relatively light-hearted
tone Frank Miller had scrapped virtually
all of this and effectively rebooted
daredevil by not only making daredevil a
much darker character but by also
changing the origin story of Jack
Murdock to making him a man who is a
abusive alcoholic as opposed to someone
who was teaching Matt Murdock patience
and and the value of education now in
addition to the changes that were made
by Frank Miller to
character in history Frank Miller also
introduced the character of stick as
Daredevils mentor as well as the love
interest an eventual villain in the form
of Elektra now while these changes had
effectively split the daredevil fanbase
down the middle ultimately the daredevil
sales begin to increase and as a result
Frank Miller's Run has become the
quintessential run of daredevil in terms
of his publication history but following
Frank Miller's critically acclaimed run
on daredevil a handful of writers tried
to undertake the mantle of continuum
where Frank Miller left off but the
problem is that they were unsuccessful
due to either being unable to continue
writing for daredevil due to their own
particular assignments or because they
were simply unable to maintain the level
of standard the Frank Miller had set and
so what we found was that in the late
1980s
now the daredevil series was taken over
by a woman named Ann Nichols in t and n
Niko since he actually became the
longest-running writer for daredevil
which lasted about four years and she
wrote between issues 238 to issues 291
now in addition to maintaining the
darker tones of Frank Miller had
established with daredevil she also
began to focus on issues of feminism and
drug abuse and this actually led her to
become way I guess a writer that
contended with Frank Miller in terms of
the publication history and the
character development and rear
involvement of fragrant and the
daredevil fans not from the 1990s
leading into the 2000s Derrida will
continue to see a change in writing
after an Nicko since he had left an
individual such as Kevin Smith Joe Kelly
Brian Michael Bendis and even Ed
Brubaker had taken on the position of
writing for daredevil and each of them
managed to contribute their own
individual thing which should be rolled
over into the next rider in terms of how
it was daredevil was written but any
kind of critically acclaimed stories
that existed for daredevil actually
didn't really return until 2001 when
Jeff Loeb had written the critically
acclaimed story called Marvel Knights
daredevil yellow and what this did was
effectively rewrite the history of
daredevil not an extreme degree the way
the Frank Miller had done but sort of
fine-tuned things and currently as it
stands now in terms of Marvel leading
into their 2015 summer event Mark Waid
is currently writing for daredevil is
actually doing a pretty spectacular job
at it
what this being said I'm gonna go ahead
and bring this video to an end I hope
you guys enjoyed it if you did let me
know and I will catch you guys later